Zach all right the first time I'm struck
by is you've you've really slimmed down
quite a bit
thank you I've done a lot of have had a
lot of plastic surgery a lot of work
done on a lot of work on my torso and my
face though yeah but no I just I kind of
just started not eating that's a great
diet just no no II don't know no Weight
Watchers few just you cut out all food
no food now I tend not to eat I
shouldn't say this here no no go ahead
say I tend not to eat food advertised on
television food advertised on television
you mean the food those commercials they
show that keep our show in business
that's the food you avoid is that what
you're saying nope I didn't say that at
all fast food you might ask food you
can't do you have to eat whole food
whole grains and that kind of stuff and
you have to cut out like whipped cream
pizzas I disagree nightly Jeff who are
our big advertisers
Oh whipped cream whip eat Sacko
nobody likes food which ones like
McDonald's Burger King some of the best
food there is right
[Applause]
that's all we eat at my house you didn't
know but you're living shitty but yeah I
would hate to be you you have a horrible
life so that's true use your eating
healthy food now give her miss that's
her furniture Sorry Sorry
I get so nervous when these I'm sorry
I'm good yeah no is this better
yeah yes yes please no man's pretty now
you slim down I know that part of you
know cuz many times you'd come on our
show and do all kinds of jokes and you
used to like to do fat jokes about
yourself do you miss doing those now
well I'm not that skinny I know I don't
do fat jokes about myself anymore I'm
they don't seem to work I do it more
about you know somebody that might be a
little bigger like Chris Christie is
right guys
you take the jokes that you used to do
about yourself and you just turn them on
other yeah they work better for Chris
Christie that they did for me right
which one of them is did you know that
Chris oh this is gonna be a good one did
you know that Chris did you know that
Chris Christie uh
is suing doughnuts oh really doughnuts
yeah why because of the whole
[Applause]
have you seen that movie end of watch
has anybody seen that movie end of watch
end of watch it's suppose that's a big
movie right now end of what it's about
I don't it's about when Chris Christie
sat on his roll it okay now listen
this is working out great for you